el sábado pasado nacieron las dos
hermanitas de guillermo las llamaron
nadie y vanessa nadie a peso 4.300 12
kilogramos y midió 51 centímetros de
largo
vanessa peso 3 puntos 98 kilos cuál es
el peso total de las dos recién nacidas
aquí lo que haremos es saber el peso de
ambas bebés
por lo que estos 51 centímetros de largo
no los tomaremos en cuenta simplemente
nos están dando información de más para
despistarlos pero nosotros somos muy
listos y no caeremos en eso así que solo
tomaremos las medidas de kilogramos
veamos tenemos entonces que nadie a peso
4.312 y vanessa peso 3.98
vamos a sumar estos dos pesos para tener
el peso total de las dos recién nacidas
pongamos en blanco los puntos para que
los podamos distinguir y sepamos que
estamos perfectamente alineados
y aquí estamos
ahora haremos nuestras sumas recuerden
de derecha a izquierda
pongamos este 0 que nos está completando
el segundo número para tener tres
columnas completas y hagamos ahora si
nuestra suma 2 + 0 es igual a 2 1 + 8 es
igual a 9 mientras que 3 más 9 es igual
a 12 tenemos 12 en los decimales y lo
correremos o llevaremos hacia las
unidades la decena que nos está sobrando
de este lado y ahora tenemos uno más 4
es igual a 5 5 3 es igual a 8
por lo que el peso de las dos recién
nacidas fue igual a 8.292 kilogramos
entre ambas